uh but I think the best thing to do to
start out is to is to see if we can't
come up with as a group with a proof
that uh that Dexter's end State method
uh always does get into the good States
um because we we need to have some ideas
not only of proof techniques for
for counter examples that is something
uh definitely makes a loop and of bad
States and therefore bad configurations
and therefore is is uh is unsuitable but
we also have to have a way of doing the
other things saying that there is no
Loop of bad configurations and this
means a a proof of some sort
um and uh I uh so I look forward to
seeing if if you can uh working together
come up with a rigorous uh proof of the
uh of the fact that there aren't any
things so let's look at diagster's
General construction of uh of this thing
for uh arbitrary and and uh
um let's see what was it again
um the the processor is zero
um F0 of um
of uh what did somebody have to have the
nuncio yeah thanks man
that's fun okay f of x zero of x y z and
then left right middle and Center Y is
equal to
um
um y plus one if
x equals y
and otherwise
five
and if sub I of x y z was just X
and this is for I greater than zero uh
well we have
we have a squeaky board here I'll try
not to
try not to pounce on it too much okay
that's that's the uh definition so now
we've got uh
uh
uh this means that we we know that we
eventually have good Cycles where
there's only uh where we'll get a value
like uh say n is is uh is six or
something like that we're we're
eventually going to get to a situation
like four four four four four four three
three uh which will go to four four four
four four four four four four four four
three I mean and you know
and then that'll go through five four
four four four and so on
um and then the five will carry over to
a zero and I will
and this was mod this was mod end this
particular
y plus one means my name and this was
and these good States once we get into a
good situation we'll always repeat but
the question is well how do we know
that we're always going to get to a good
state
what's the answer
make things a little easier to see is if
we just looked at the differences
between states the differences between
states instead of the states okay so the
differences between states modulo
is uh
uh would would say that uh you've got
zero zero zero
zero
I think well you want to consider the
difference of left minus yourself let's
say huh
let's be like that
and then the different then that
difference moves with moves over
until we got all zeros
three right the rules involved
all right what happened yeah
oh I see rewrite the rules in terms of
differences okay let's try that
no we can't
that requires more knowledge doesn't it
I mean is there well I mean if you are
what is this rule go into in terms of
differences
well like you know that the difference
between zero and one is
yeah okay
I like to I'd like to do it in terms of
differences if I can let's try to see if
I can figure out let's call the
let's see p was the state so p is the
state and Q would be
Q of I would be equal to Q
um
I minus 1 minus q i
mean
p i minus one
minus PI right and
um and so then we want G
so by of um
of x y z
of
of Q
I want G to be the function on on
differences with states that that
corresponds to F1
on States and so we have f
of
P left P middle P right
is equal to P Prime
then G of Q left Q middle Q right is
supposed to equal Q Prime that's what
we're trying to do find the function G
that does this okay
so
um
I don't
think we have enough
information because because Q oh let's
see qm
so so uh how do we do this so cute
um we know then that ql
is equal to P left left neighbor right
well I mean if you look at it
I don't like my notation yeah if x is
wrong if x equals y that is if the if
the inter Delta is zero yeah
um then
um that difference is it just goes to
one
okay
um
so like so Q zero and what what about
this one
um
basically that Q sub I would be
would go to zero and then Q sub I plus
one would be the old Q sub I plus one
plus Q sub I
so in other words when this when this
guy moves
and his neighbor doesn't move
his right neighbor changes changes Delta
so yeah I mean every every move involves
a change of two adjacent deltas
but two people can move simultaneously
well it's not I mean it's not the
processor
um if you know I don't I mean I also
have
I also have things like four five six
four
five zero one two three goes to
um for example um
for
four five zero
seven three
nine
all right
um
and even the idea is that you you can I
mean you can describe this as the state
of the processors by just the array of
deltas and then yeah and then you have
rules for saying for just saying when a
given pair of adjacent pair of Deltas
can change
because that way when you I mean all the
good configurations just consist of line
of zeros with a single one somewhere and
then you rules say that you're the one
that the only move that can happen is
the one moves to the right yeah well
there's a case of all zeros also and
then
the way you take care of the bad
configurations is that anything that's
not a
any any anything that's non-zero will
eventually disappear cancel with
something else is non-zero
I I think it's going to take an awful
long time to get this way because it's
because it's a config it's a the Deltas
uh the rules aren't local with Deltas
there's going to be I mean a situation
like this look what happened on
adulthood
we got a uh one
um a a five
um
has gone into
five zero
five five
zero zero zero zero zero five
one minus three is four
come on
four minus four is zero four minus five
it's not minus one five minus zero is
five zero minus one is minus one one
minus three is minus two
all right I'm
um
it's getting the same thing here
I don't know anyway it doesn't look it
doesn't look very promising to me and I
and there's many ways to there's many
ways to start but I think this one
I mean if when I got several things
moving in a row it looks complicated to
me
so I'm going to change these things
another idea Mike yeah this one is just
trying to
um
keep track of how many different numbers
appear in the Cyclone try to prove that
the number of different numbers is going
to decrease okay not yeah so what we
we'd like to do is have some kind of a
condition that'll show us that we get
eventually to a good configuration and
one criteria is to try to keep track of
the number of of distinct uh of distinct
uh uh elements in there
um
uh and see if we if if we can show
something about that this this uh
inexorably marches down to zero
um
because it doesn't stay at zero yeah we
I mean why the number of distinct things
goes two two then goes one temporarily
and back to two all right so there's a
case in which uh in which it it
increases
um
what's the case that that number
increases
the number of distinct uh label the
number of this of distinct States
increases in what in
in this case here when when it's when
the two extreme guys have the same value
then on the next move
we can introduce a new value
and we'll be there
so please put an example of uh of one
going to the state because I think just
looking at the actual values
something going into this
okay so so let's take a bad one that
goes into this one what what's an
example
um one way is to have
uh
like X
for x
three three
we're going
all right
our our console 3x no X could be
anything like that
the problem is that the number of
different digits doesn't decrease much
we've got a complicate the conditions
yeah the condition yeah we got to have a
mark another another thing
um now if by the way another proposal to
try to prove something is to try to
disprove it
I I I don't know this applies more to
game players I think but it's much you
can get more of your juices working in
if you try to show that something is
wrong and if you try to show something
right because I mean if you're naturally
a nitpicker like I am anyway this is
true that you know let's let's let's
just uh instead of proving it let's just
construct a uh an infinite cycle of bad
configurations
um and then if we if we you know that
this gives us a sort of a positive uh
thing you know let's just this is true
that the darn thing is wrong and Dykstra
made a mistake okay everybody makes
mistake and uh and then we uh um and
then uh once we have that of course then
we don't have to bother proving it
because it's false uh but also uh also
we might get stuck and then that'll give
us an idea how we could how we can make
a proof so so let's suppose we have an
infinite uh you know an infinite
sequence of configuration they're all
bad
um so this goes on and on and on
um can we prove something about this if
an infinite set of configurations
uh that um
uh
for example um well let's see how can we
prove
about it could we prove that the uh
can we prove that um
all the processors move or something
like that so so I suppose I had an
infinite sequence of could I have an
infinite sequence in which in which uh
some of them are cycling back and forth
but others are are constant if you have
any infinite sequence you you can you
can there's two cases where either
either the processor eventually
converges to a to a fixed state or else
it or else it actually moves okay so so
um I think
there's got to be
uh put let's take zero processors there
zero processor and an infinite sequence
is it possible to go on and on with the
zero processor never moving
that's equ that's one one example
can we can we go on and on and on and
the zero processor starts at some value
um
I guess we could assume it could be any
arbitrary value
so suppose the zeros that's a stuck at
fault right we got zero processors it's
stuck at some value that means that we
never we never come to this situation
where where where the zero point one
moves now is that
is that is that is that conceivable
ah and here Dimitri no why and it goes
uh what the other processes do is just
copy their left value yeah So eventually
the value of 0.5
will be copied to everybody okay now why
is now that's a good that's a good point
it looks like if we give if the zero
processor is equal to uh it's in state
zero for example then
um then we can't go on and on without
having everybody get to state zero
how do we actually prove this rigorously
hope that you can't make someone of a
recurrence relation that says that first
you know if you can only hold off moving
uh copying the zeroth value to the first
value
for as long as it takes to move
everything from
to the right of that
for the amount of time that it'll take
to get to this well that would you'd
have to find you below that you'd have
to move it below that point because okay
otherwise you'd exhaust that's a very
that's a that's proving more that's even
getting a balanced statement that uh
well yeah but uh but that's an
interesting uh thing a sub problem uh
how long can we keep it going uh uh you
know if the if the maximum amount of
time we keep it going is infinite then
we then we've got it rather but it's the
maximum amount of time I mean let's
suppose for example that we got the
situation uh now now I'm I'm keeping
this guy fixed at zero and this is X1 X2
X3 X4 and the only operations I can do
from step to step is that I have to copy
somebody to the right
um how long how long could it possibly
take before they before they were all
zeros
and uh you know the first move might be
uh
um to to copy two dice or you know
um
like that but there's a there might not
be the slowest way to go of this but but
the idea is that eventually we think
we're going to have all zeros at the
bottom how long can it possibly take and
you're working you want to give a a
recurrence
I was just going to say well I guess I
would probably be right uh
what you want to do is say that if the
if you figure out when you have to move
a copy of the zeroth one to the first
one is when you've exhausted all
possible moves like that and when you
have to move to the next one is okay so
so for example if if X1 now
we sort of have an induction that says
that um suppose that X1 never moves
um uh if X1 never moves then uh then by
the previous case X2 X3 X4 would have to
eventually be equal to one so you can go
at most F of
um so let's call let's say the F of uh
of four
or let's say N N Sub 4 is that is a is
the maximum number of moves until this
becomes all zeros and one thing you can
say is that
um uh N Sub 4
is less than or equal to looks like N
Sub three percent plus percent of two
percents of one
because it's each time you move it over
one M sub three plus oh actually another
four well that's a very easy spelling
yeah it's not clear okay in at least
three moves we're gonna have we're gonna
have to move x one right and then I mean
although that's you can say that in N
Sub 2 you have to move another one
oh well after that we have zero zero
then it looks like N Sub three again
no no because your other three numbers
are automatically
no no but we haven't yeah we haven't we
haven't uh necessarily gone to this we
haven't necessarily gone up yet
to that worst case we haven't gone to
the
to the uh uh the I mean I I don't have
to go all the way to N3
uh I might uh I might have decided to
move X1 right away in order to get a
rigorous proof uh I I can't uh take the
worst case on on one side and then take
and say now for the other side I I
assume that I'll use the worst case
still offensive two because then you
still uh from that position you have
with two zeros you want to know how long
you can hold X2 fix now
and that sense of two
well oh I could I could just say how
long can I hold if I'm going with that
with X with this equals zero but it's
the N Sub two plus N Sub 1 plus yeah
so it's it's that's going up that's
that's going up like two to the end but
it's all it says in a finer number of
steps
um we we're finally get the zero
spreading all around here
um it uh
might be interesting to look at the
that's the real worst case instead of
getting this due to the end bomb it
looks like in two of the end steps were
were down shortly to it but not but but
uh I was waiting for somebody to give me
a real simple proof that that at least
it's finite Mike well you can I I can
move the band onto
the thing that Mike mentioned the
previously saying look at the number of
different
X's that always decreases every move uh
if uh no it doesn't that's not true
because it's Tuesday yeah n plus one
that's like it doesn't increase because
you can move but if you order them I um
okay zero four three two one okay so
they so the the transition between
between different ones
something like Roger's uh development
idea where we put up we put in tick
marks between different values
then we can make a then we can see what
happens
um to the to the tick marks that every
at every move
um namely
um
the uh What uh in words instead of
keeping track of Delta that the the
actual differences between them just
required non-zero differences
and a tick mark means that if possible a
potential non-zero difference now what
can happen uh when you when when we go
from one from one step to another
is that
we can either that the the new tick mark
um uh is is either changed to zero
or the
um let's see what do we have here what
are the transitions on tick marks now
so if I have something like X
y with a tick mark here
um
so so let's look at the at the
neighborhood of a of a of a of a of a
tick mark uh so if if there's if there's
a sort of a zero on a chicken and a zero
that means the two two equal and then
and then what then now after this
um the uh only possible moves that I can
get are actually are to erase that that
Mark right
um or but but it might move to this so
we could go so if if I if I move this X
over here then that would
that would give me this this progression
tick marks on this on this side
um if
um
uh
let's see if that moves at all that's
what
happens
because this x would this x uh has to be
X next time this can be either an X or Y
this has to be a y next time
um so so uh I I get
this situation
that that zero zero kick zero has to go
into itself or zero zero or that if it
moves at all the next thing is um is
situation like um
um
xxyz
and uh the uh the successors of that
um
uh
are
gosh I don't know but I don't know if
I'm doing this
um optimally
it looks like it looks like in the next
move I can I I can either change this y
to an X which obliterates this guy
um or I can
change this C to a y which would be a
zero took zero rather than zero zero
zero six zero right
and then or I can do both
if you do both
if I do both I get an X over here and a
y over there that's this that's this one
again
and um
preferably move something but
unfortunately what's happening is if I
change the Y Z to A Y I'm affecting that
I'm affecting the uh
um the tick mark on on the right of that
one there
so so I'm getting into the same trouble
I was worrying about with Rogers
suggestion before that I gotta find out
I've got to find a place where I gotta
find an anchor to uh for my rules but
somehow intuitively that I'm going to a
looking at it in terms of tick marks is
is a is giving me a uh is giving me sort
of a graph of uh where I have to go to a
a more rightward configuration at every
step and uh that the longest path in
this graph is what we're trying to find
well well Mike just uh came up with the
zero four three two one okay zero four
three two one it does from five to six
elements to Florida state governments
and then it stays at four distinct
elements goes back up to five before
going down again okay so how do you do
this you just well good it's everything
moves so it's everything moves at first
so it's let's go zero zero oh I'm sorry
not the first time first time it's just
one fourth one four three two one
is the first time
yeah okay start it one four three two
this is the starting position right and
this is stage zero I mean this is the
guy I wrote for zero here sure
I think that works it goes to
uh next guy is let's say it would be two
two four two one no no no two oh but I'm
not I'm holding this guy fixed
I'm holding I'm trying to say how long
can I keep going with with uh with
processor zero sitting at a set of fixed
value
and never mind
but there's a
there you go now that's another
optimization problem that we're going
but I I'm just thinking that this is an
interesting sub problem because these
other these other uh these other guys
eventually uh have to become all zeros
in the question mark and we've shown
that it's finite and lost two to the end
steps or something like that we're going
to get all zeros in there uh the
argument on that again was saying that
uh we know that uh
um uh in in at least if this is N4 if N
Sub 4 Moves is the maximum where we can
keep going
um without making this into all zero uh
I mean without
without
changing uh yeah without changing zero
then
um N Sub three moves would be the
maximum we could go without changing X1
so after N Sub three moves we would have
to change X1 and make it equal to zero
then
um uh uh then in in sub two moves we
would have to change
X2 and make it equal to zero and N Sub 1
moves we have to change X3 and make it
equal zero
and uh
uh probably by that time Expo would be
zero
so we get up so we would get a bound it
goes something like 2 to the N is this I
think it's just yeah we agree if we look
at any one tick mark yeah that it can If
It Moves it can only move to the right
okay okay let's uh like any so I I if
you if you have uh uh you know if we got
yeah we notice that the total number of
tick marks never um never decreased
never never increases I'm sorry okay our
increases and and and whatever we make a
move at least one tick Mark has to agree
correct right because the tick marks
have to change yeah look at each tick
mark then and see how long it can stare
and how many moves it can stay around
for okay how long can the can the first
tick mark stay okay so so uh in the
worst case it'll move off the Right End
okay so so you say that when a tick mark
disappears it moves off the Right End
absolutely worst case because it could
run into another tick mark and disappear
okay so we so people can disappear in
the middle too can't they tick marks can
disappear in the middle so so uh a tick
mark really means a um a
a boundary between um
uh like I can either keep in order to
keep an identification of these tick
marks so that we can we can see them
from from one step to another it sort of
means the the right most
boundary of of a certain value
something like that
um like like I mean I could
I'm trying to find that I'm trying to
find a way to to you know when you say
that a tick mic moves to the right that
means that uh somehow we've been able to
identify we've been able to map the the
three tick marks at one step to the
three tick marks at the next step and um
and one way to do it is probably to
identify
um this as a as zero one two three by
the means of the label it by the by the
the guy to to the left of the tick mark
so then then um uh the the the uh that
makes it obvious that the tick Mark has
to go to the right to move to the right
at all if if it moves at all because uh
the only way things happen is by copying
a value over to over one step to the
right
and so the tick marks now represent them
to the maximum rightward extent of a
particular value
in the in the
thing okay so now uh then uh it it shows
then that uh uh three can
and like this this tick mark number
three can move at most one time
this one can move at most two twice this
one at most three times this one almost
four times so now we get a bond of N
squared we get a bound of uh of uh n
plus n minus one plus n minus two
squared plus n over two right so we get
so we go from two to the N to n o n
Square end of the two uh half of that
okay so that so it looks like uh in
approximately N squared steps were
we at most we're forced to move zero of
course we're not forced to move zero
when it first to hold off and wait until
they're all zero before we move zero
it's possible to do what uh what now you
were getting at uh Rich a minute ago
saying that you can also keep going a
long time but still moving zero anyway
we found that problem though that
eventually the thing has to go
has to move from zero
um now
um let's look at the example temporarily
that you that you uh
that you had so you had one four three
two one the first the last three equal
and you have a degree yeah and now you
want to go from this to
two
one one four three two and just keep
cycling it around you get three two one
four three
but you actually increase the number of
distinct elements there at the end all
right so
now for otherwise that would have been
in a bad a bad Loop um in fact that
would have been a counter example
if I had
um
uh if my States if I had five if I had
four states and five processors that
would have been a counter example
on and on
but I have five states and five
processors here
how are you going to get that cycle
because I mean can you get it again
and now okay
so so here's a case where the first one
is moving a lot but we still have to
show something else but now but anyway
our first argument then in order to show
that there is no infinite sequence of
bad moves
uh uh was to show that in any sequence
of bad moves uh uh uh the first
processor has to
has to move infinitely often in any
infinite sequence of bad moves if we're
going to construct one it's going to
involve moves by the by processor zero
over and over and over again because we
can't keep processor zero stuck
and so uh we're we're bound to have if
we do have an infinite sequence of bad
moves it's going to involve process is
zero cycling through different states
over and over again
okay now if if that's true
then processor zero is going to have to
get to the situation that
that um it's able to move
um so that it's another point that we
can make is that no matter where we if
in any any long sequence of bad bad
configurations the processor n minus one
the guy at the right hand side is going
to have to uh
become equal to processor zero in order
for processor zero to move
all right well now Hulk how can we
show that to clinch the argument that
that and so that that nothing is going
to go on and on
um
uh by the way look what would happen if
we wait a minute
for
zero
if I had started this out
with zeros here
foreign
then I would have a a one here
and zero there
and two here still is that right excuse
me
oh okay it's no good I'm gonna say start
with it make it four three two one zero
it just add another one yeah four three
two one zero that would have thought
that would have uh
sisters now that's right
see I got now six processors so I should
let be around Six States
okay well make it three two one zero
three two one zero what I was trying to
get at is some kind of a there's got to
be another Force there's not gotta be
another idea in here that is uh
um
that's going to uh that's going to show
that we we can't keep on
on uh like this we can't keep on looping
forever
so
I get to a situation where
where I know that I suppose that that we
have an infinite sequence of bad
configurations and
um and uh by without loss of generality
we can suppose that processor zero
starts out in state zero
um so this this started out uh somehow
or other now we were able to conclude
that after a finite number of steps we
would get into a situation where this
last one was Zero
uh you say eventually in that other
situation it came out that all of the
processors came out to different values
if you ever have a long time you have to
different values and you'll never get
the first element
position almost all of them are equal
okay now say that again Richard if you
have all distinct element uh values
in the processors yeah if all these are
distinct
then the only way you're going to get is
uh zero in the right hand one is to have
all of the zeros right if they're all
distinct then then this then they'll
have to be zero okay now that's that
that's let's go a little bit slower in
in state state this very carefully I
think this is okay uh suppose without
loss of generality that the first that
we start out with a zero some stage we
call it zero in the first processor
um I guess to be more General we could
call it a and okay then we don't even
have to lose it not only are we we can
say without loss of generality but we're
keeping all generality
um then we know that in in zero or more
time steps after that we're going to get
to a situation like this where the X's
will have changed perhaps in two y's but
that that the final one has to has has
to be equal to this x the reason that
the reason is that we know that a can't
stay forever and So eventually a so
there's going to be a time when this
goes to a plus one
um and and what this can't happen unless
the previous move brought an a over
there
so so we we know that in finitely many
steps something like N squared over two
steps uh at the worst but you maybe in
most steps maybe it's already true that
x n minus one equals a but eventually
we're going to have to get to a
situation where there's an a at the end
here so there are only two cases there
either they're all A's or or they are
well
if they aren't then the first one will
start will increment and again you'll go
until the election is eight plus one
then we're in a good configuration and
we know the secret we know the history
of this because because that's that's
done so suppose they aren't all eggs
well then one of the elements x12x n
minus one had to be a okay now why is
that so
that's the only thing they do is
copied from the left yeah so if there
was so if none of these were if if none
of these were a
then uh then the only way to get an A
over here is to is to have it has to
have come from somewhere to its left and
and wherever that was so so somehow this
egg originated uh in in this in you know
somewhere to the left of itself and uh
and uh therefore there must have been
there must have been an a already there
in the X's yeah I mean what I was saying
was that let us say that this is the
first time for after after the initial
set this is the first occurrence where
you have as both in the beginning and
the end okay okay then this last element
must have changed into a in the lab
previous step in in the last day
or else it was our initial configuration
okay but yeah it could have been our
starting configuration yeah but
if it's not then the previous step would
have had to have an A here
yeah in which case and then you can sort
of okay so so there were so now we've
got a proof then that uh one of these
X's if if we're going to construct this
infinite sequence a bad one
we've got to choose we gotta put an a
into one of these X's here
okay now the first one
what
we got to put an a somewhere in there if
we don't then then then
we're bound to get a situation where
we've got a straight A's here
the first element goes to a plus one and
it'll continue that way and until you
either get all the same element or it
Cycles through all the possible States
okay so all the possible States then
you're gonna come out so now we've got
an A plus one situation
um and then but these these might
be be varying Somehow Here
uh
on the next in the next batch uh still
have to get some kind of a
stick we still gotta notice that
one more one more fact about this
there's I think a proof of of
impossibility is about to is about to be
found but I uh but those who have
already spoken three times should not
announce it
okay so in order to so so what we got to
do is construct a a bad situation and
what we got and and one of the things we
found out if we're going to have this
infinite long sequence is that that we
had better
I put an a somewhere
uh if a is our first value here we
better put an a somewhere in in among
the other guy
otherwise we're sure to get into a good
good configuration
okay then then what's happened is after
the then we got an A plus one sitting
here and uh
um and then these others have moved in
some
in some fashion
to produce these guys
there'd also be a better be an A plus
one in here right an A plus one needed
in here
in in among and and in particular it's
got to be among
among um these guys
you're gonna have to have an A plus a
plus one
among the Y's extremely wait for it
because it's not among the A's right so
eight plus one among the Y's yeah
and here we got a was an element of X1
x n minus one
uh incense we've only generated one a
plus one they couldn't have gotten
through to the Y's yet so the a plus one
must have also started in the axis yep
so the a plus one so the Y is our subset
of the X's
so then so we have an A plus one is also
an element of X1 through x n minus one
and there we get a plus two and all the
naught okay so now you're going to show
that all in numbers
that are in the set X1 through xn minus
one
that's going to be hard to do together n
different numbers in and out and now n
minus one element six okay so let's see
if we can carry on the induction to the
show that a plus two also is in this x's
and that ought to that ought to work and
and I think that's true you see if a
plus one is here now eventually then
we're going to get to a situation where
there's an A plus one at the bottom here
and there's going to be some z's here
foreign
and uh
and what do we conclude about disease
that disease
aren't necessarily in among the X's but
they're in the in the X's or a plus one
so I think they are the best thing we
can do we can conclude that a
a plus
two
vitamin A
yeah we're gonna we're gonna want to
show that a plus two is a member of Z1
through z n minus two
and we and and we also have Z1 through
ZN minus two is a subset of
a plus one or
X
a r a a or a plus one or x one through x
n minus one
that's too sloppy but I got but I guess
I think that's the the basic idea of the
proof that that and and that and we're
using the fact that we've got n States
in every machine then that doesn't
matter because a plus one and a are also
numbers of X ones right n minus one so
you can just get rid of those two ah
good
yeah because we've already proved that
those are in there okay
so but these are yeah disease aren't
necessarily contained in the excess but
the Z and the A and and the plus one
okay so so somehow the the the the fact
that when we got to this point
um and we know there's two A's in there
that are equal to at least two of the
states are equal then then we must have
one missing state by this time
so soon earlier we get to a point where
where we're missing at least one of the
possible States in one of the processors
okay well that that state is the if that
one's missing we're never going to see
it again until
uh we get to the point where
um uh where uh
processor one moves into that state
and processor one that that missing
State processor one will never move into
the missing State unless
um that unless all this in this unless
we've gotten a good configuration
everything equal to missing State minus
one
that's um that's the way we get a proof
of
impossibility
okay now
um so so the fact that uh
uh that we had in States was was used in
this and of course in the problem we
want to try to come down with a small
number of states now n to the n
and the small product of the number of
states not n to the n and diagster had
this other method
that uh that uses only three states per
processor does anybody uh
had anybody found a good intuitive
explanation for his three his three-step
method what do you
what do you guys think Andy eat either
one I'll look at both of you see next to
each other
so so
um
uh you see
the uh I think the main problem in uh in
these cases where
where we had we did have infinite Cycles
where uh
we had lots and lots of bad bad things
going on
um
was if you got a ring here and to the
people on this side of the Ring it looks
like
uh it looks like it's time for them to
move
and make some advance in
um by by moving the passing the Baton or
something to the to somebody on your
right or on the left moving in some
direction and
um and similarly it might look locally
um to the people over here that it's
time to move
and
if they can just keep on moving like
that over and over again and but but a
situation where where two different
people are able to move two different
processes they're able to move then they
can't be good configurations and a good
configuration only one can move and
um
uh so the the uh we would just keep on
going uh bad situation with the two with
the two on opposite sides never knowing
that that they weren't the only ones
able to move
you only know about your neighbors
um and uh we have to have some way of
avoiding this kind of an infinite
um
an infinite cycle
um so
um how now Dexter's method here with end
States uh
gets around it by having a
uh when you pass state zero it has some
kind of a filter
that that require that sort of gets rid
of one one of the
uh extra states that was
if you look at the total set of states
that are originally present
at least they're somehow wait until we
reduce that
eventually we get down to the fact that
we could have if we started out with n
different states so here we have to have
at most n minus one
um I think eventually we we get down to
n minus two and so on
so his his method with um with three
processors we ought to look at
and take a look at the yeah three states
I'm sorry
you've got um unless somebody else wants
to bring up another Point Roger I had a
really nice argument with those Deltas I
was talking about earlier problems I
totally left out the possibility of two
processors moving at the same time
but the thing is I mean with the delses
if you only see you can only have one
processor moving at any given point he's
just you just got the two adjacent ones
changing and so
I mean with three states your Delta is
either going to be zero one or negative
one and your ideal situations are just
you just have an isolated one or an
isolated negative one floating around
and the ones go this way and the
negative ones go that way
and whenever they Collide goes this way
and the negative ones go that way well
you're going around the ring okay yeah
let's take a look at the uh at the
three-state solution
um I'll I'm going to be proved wrong
that the Deltas are better but it looks
like having one processor move at a time
is is simpler to see than than having
two Deltas move at a time but I'm not
sure because uh because you you do map
uh the uh it's relative to the relative
to uh to one of the others or something
like that yeah go ahead and you know it
it seems to be in most of these cases
pretty easy to show that once you're in
a good good configuration you you stay
in a cycle of good configuration
all the time
that
that you never get stuck in a cycle
without it
it seems to be in most cases pretty easy
to show that
once you're in a good good configuration
you you stay in a cycle of good
configurations
it's the other half it seems to be the
harder to prove it all the time
but uh
that you never get stuck in a cycle of
God
in fact I'm not sure if anybody's ever
proved
oh in print approved it for this case
um
put in my black one
I think I'm just going to leave out the
case of it where it stays equal to Y so
this would move this one would move if
y plus one equals X
r
y plus one equals z
and then FN minus one the last one
is
equal to
um X plus one we have x equals z
okay these are the whose was this behind
here so okay so now that's good so now
in this case the moving
um
that's probably out of the middle part
of the middle process has been removing
is always uh is always up by one and so
there's always there's a there's there's
a general idea of going
going up up up up in this case you know
the modulo three
um
and um
so in the good in a good situation
uh of course you have to have the right
the right um
uh people around you there uh but the
idea is what that that we start out with
um
say zeros I got it here
now in the in the middle one thing they
move up if they have a neighbor who's
equal to to to uh the one they want to
move to so they're going to move to when
they move up they do move to uh if they
are copying the state of one of their
neighbors
um
nor if we're not blocking zero zero zero
zero then it's gonna
we're gonna have to get it from the
beginning of the end
um
y plus 1 equals z this goes to the other
one if your neighbor
if you're if if your right neighbor
is different from is is one Higher you
go down so this so the one on the left
is always moving
is always moving down
um
guy on the right
is looking
just looking to see whether he's got
equal
x and z that's this guy equal to this
guy and so then he then he moves up by
one so this guy
goes up to zero zero zero one so
now
from this situation
he's already moved
and um this one would want to go down to
two or to minus one but to say to two
uh but only if
only if the neighbor is one so this is
going to go to zero one zero zero one
one and then zero one one and then
uh and then this is yeah this is a this
this guy is finally able to move but
instead of going to zero one one it goes
to two one one
um
yeah well
all right
so now who moves next
okay so now
that that it looks like it looks like
this guy gets to move yeah so so um
let me write it down here maybe I don't
know if I'm doing this Optimum way then
this one's close to two two one one and
uh we got a wave going to the right now
two two one
okay and then
um the
uh then x and z are equal in the in the
last guys
um
and last guy's thing so so it goes to
zero and goes to two two zero
so this goes to two two two zero
which is the same as
zero zero zero one under Deltas under
under Rogers uh idea that these are if
we look at the at the differences uh
adding one to all all the states is
equivalent
uh so two two two zero
n0001 behave the same
so so the the main idea then in this in
this case if you can imagine having end
processors where n is much greater than
four will just be to
to widen this ring
and um the uh it goes three times around
the loop before it gets back to zero
zero zero one but but eventually it does
and uh as Anil said the
uh as Anil said the the hard part is
going to be to show that every every
initial every way of starting with zeros
ones and twos is got to get to uh it's
got to get to uh one of these good
configurations sooner or later
um
Ramsay had a nice uh a nice way of
describing this to me when he when we
were discussing this problem the first
week
um uh it's sort of like you've got
there's there's a way of going to the
left a two to the right here and then a
wave coming to the left
um and um
if you if you uh and and these if the
waves run into each other then they
cancel out
uh so that if you so if you if we're
trying to get an infinite sequence
um we could get one if we had only waves
going around to the right by this this
by this cycle that I mentioned uh before
I suppose we had this large cycle and
there were only three states everywhere
uh then then it would be uh you know if
if if everything would always be moving
always to the right it seems that uh
to be impossible or at least very uh I
couldn't see how to do it
um to to find a way that that we could
we could remove the infinite uh
sequence of bad configurations where
everybody thought that they were able to
move if the waves were always going to
the right
but if some if waves in all the good
Cycles have to go both right and then
left and right and then left then then I
I uh then we're not getting this
infinite situation because the the two
two uh if you're in two parts of a of
the cycle at once the the they're gonna
somehow butt against each other and
cancel out
um you've been in a football stadium
where there's these waves going around
the uh the uh the crowd you know what I
mean it's a it's a
um the only way to stop it is to send up
a wave going the other direction
but sometimes that even goes around a
while
okay
um
well
oh what time is it going to be I wanna
for goodness
except they're okay
um
trying to see what we should do with
that last few minutes uh this morning
in order to get to the to the main
um
uh
uh the main problem of course we're
trying to we're trying to uh
see if we can't beat three to the end
for the total number of states
in a
totalum configurations in the end State
system that's self-stabilizing
and
one of the uh
ways to do it would be to try to stick a
few twos in the middle of the ring uh at
least we're going to have to have one of
them two states if we're going to do
better than three to the end
and uh okay so
uh another thing is is for example
notice that 4 times 2 is less than three
times three
so maybe
if you could substitute a two next to a
four
I might be able to
do better or you know the same kind of a
situation as three and three
um
we we have to have some kind of a
some kind of a way of knowing what not
only what the good configurations are
going to be but also uh a way to to damp
down the bad ones into a into a finite
cycle
um
I I guess there may the the best way for
me to to finish today would be to
consider the kick to show that we can't
do it with all two state
uh
you know if you've got if you got uh say
five processors and all of them with two
states that there's going to be no way
to do it let's let's take
let's take a look at that
um
so
now let's let's show it with five
processes
and two states in each processor we
can't possibly do it so the initial
state is
X1 X2 X3 X4 X5
and um
and let's suppose we have a good
configuration
uh so without loss of generality we can
assume that the X1 is the one that moves
and so it goes to the complementary
state
and so X1 moved oh processor one moved
I'm I should call it processor zero
excuse me
I I'm off by one in my subscripts okay
now
um
um who's who's gonna move next
either five or two uh okay let's say
it's two what the heck of it this we
sort of did this last week
you can think of five is actually being
much larger if you want to to anything
five or more okay now uh
now the next to move will be either
three or one now why do you say why did
you say either five or two next time
it's because they're the only ones who
whose neighborhoods have have changed in
any way and we don't want number one to
move twice in a row because then we'd be
in an infant cycle for sure
that other people are starting so that
so the uh
um now at this point it's either one or
three
and I claim it can't be one
Andy with nodded your head why why do
you agree well if it if you change one
then you'll then you'll have to you'll
get in the cycle again so I'll change
too
okay
we'll just film out and this if I change
one I have I'm forced to
so you have to change either two or five
right of five I certainly can't change
two at this point but it was the same as
original and we know that five is
blocked because because five foot move
in this in this situation right so I
have to change two again I'd be right
back to a very small Loop okay so the
main the main observation we make then
is that
it's impossible to have a situation
where one changes then two and then
and then one again
so
um this this means that if you if if you
have any ever a situation more generally
if a processor I changes followed by
processor I plus one then the next
change has to be processor I plus two
but if it's I called by minus 1 the next
change has to be I minus two
the only way to go with if you have two
states everywhere the only way to go is
um in in ways that move in the same
direction
so it's gonna so so we really have no
choice at all but to go to here
and similarly then complement X4 then X5
then X1 again and so on and that's got
it that's got to be it that's the only
way we can possibly do it in a situation
where there's hopefully there's only two
states
um and uh now
claim that this is going to lead to an
infinite configuration of bats
because we can make we can we can make
the uh whatever these X's are we could
renumber things so that they're zero so
we we might start out with zero over
here so that it looks like it's time for
for this guy to move to one but we can
also put ones in here
so it looks like to this guys if it's
his time time to move to zero
excuse me you can have two waves two
waves going around yeah because because
if it's five uh yeah if it's if if n is
five or more these two waves are going
to actually uh uh live forever
and and we can't uh you know if if one
of them starts going slower than the
other one then then it'll die out but um
all right otherwise we can't stop it and
that's the that's the way that's the
reason you can't do it in two to the end
now maybe
you know it would be sufficient to just
put one three in there
somehow uh but uh but I mean but I think
by by studying this situation a little
more generality you start to narrow down
the sets of things that
that that can't work that that can't
work this problem uh miter might not
involve computer programming you've
probably noticed uh that that is that
you're free to use computers in any way
that would help you to um to uh with
conjectures or to to study things uh
um you could uh for example make up a uh
exhaustive list of all machines with uh
with three states uh uh and see how many
of them uh hooked together would would
uh would create a pattern
like dijksters or something like that um
or it could or or you might find a
solution that's completely on on done
with uh you know pencil and paper and
not touching the machine it's not I
don't have to use computers just because
it's computer science department
sometimes we we also use our
um
okay any other remarks before we break
doesn't so but uh so uh does anybody
want to announce their solution to this
problem yeah no does anybody have one
that they think is okay finding out what
you what do you think I'm holding off
until holding off the door thanks okay
yeah well um uh it's since it's a new
problem it might be that that there will
be a very obvious solution to it
afterwards or it might turn out to be
that we get nowhere on it who knows
um certainly we know that when when you
got four processors we have a we have
only 16. um
uh
we can do it with with four processors
two states each
buy some buy some quirk
but that gives some indication some
intuition that maybe uh this three to
the N is not going to be necessary
but we it might just be something like 3
to the N minus four over I mean 16 times
3 to the N minus 4 might be the smallest
you could do with some something like
that for for large n but we we know
anyway that there are some efficient
constructions set for small n uh the
question is think big and has to if n is
real large uh how
uh how can we minimize the um the states
we don't even have to to imagine that
the processes are independent we can try
to find some construction that would
replace
One three-state processor by by a
million two-state processors if that'll
help because increasing in
um
uh also it gives you more chance to I
mean we're trying to find somehow the
something that's
that's amortized though well so if you
have the large number of processors
then we're trying to have a small
product of the states I'll just get I'll
just get myself in trouble if I try to
make sense out of this last remark
except I'm I was thinking of this we
used to we used to rate compilers on how
fast how efficient they were by saying
uh how many F lines or object code do
they generate per minute
and somebody realized that he could make
his compiler twice as efficient by just
generating twice as many lines of object
code he put in more no Ops uh into his
output and therefore and you know he
could claim his compiler did much more
per minute that way well
um we could also have a construction
that somehow has only
three independent processors but each of
them is really uh somehow a super
configuration of some some cooperating
things that are
that are going uh
uh I don't know it might be possible to
partition a set of these processors that
are simulating a processor with end
States but each of the processors only
has a small number of states themselves
I'm not sure that this makes any sense
at all but
but the
as long as we all understand the rules
of the game the the answer is to try to
find the the minimum product of
of uh of states in the in the whole in
the whole ring
okay that's all
that's all for today
foreign